welcome back New York City the epicenter
of the Cova 19 pandemic in the country
now as things are slowly beginning to
look better there how will the city
handle the reopening joining me right
now is the boss New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio mr. mayor it's great to have
you this morning thanks very much for
being here I want to ask you that
question right here how will a reopening
of New York look what industries are
poised to open first and when do you see
that happening Thank You Maria well
first of all Maria you are a proud New
Yorker proud Brooklynite by background
you know how tough and resilient this
city is so the first thing I want to say
is we will be back we will be strong in
fact we will be stronger and we're going
to create a city that builds on our
previous success and comes back stronger
and fairer I believe we can do this and
I already see the naysayers out there
saying oh York City's not gonna come
back New York City fought back after the
fiscal crisis we fought back after 9/11
we fought back after Hurricane sandy we
will fight back again what we need how
do you do it
yeah what we need there's no question my
mind we must have the support of the
federal government to do this because
right now to be able to have a strong
economy again and really restart we have
to be able to provide the basic services
that have made this place work police
fire sanitation health care education
the things that have made New York City
strong and allowed us to get through
this crisis are now in the crosshairs
because we've lost seven point four
billion dollars that's our projection
from our budget seven point four billion
in lost revenue 3.5 billion in new
expenses to pay for the corona virus and
the fight to save lives over ten billion
combined the federal government must
make us whole for us to be able to be in
a position to restart if we're not whole
if New York City is not whole it will
drag down the entire region and it will
hold it will hold up the entire national
economic restart if we are whole so how
do you want how much money do you need
from the federal government all the
money that's been lost and will be lost
lost revenue and this is true for New
York and season states around the
country we need seven point four billion
dollars that's how much we've lost
that's how much we need to get back just
like the federal government bailed out
the airline industry the tune to fifth
eight billion dollars bailout this
layout largest city in the country so we
can restart and be able to be strong
leaders in an economic revitalization in
this country we get that are you are you
you are you using this crisis to take us
into socialism I just saw you on the
press conference you said this the
bigger picture of fair recovery for all
confront structural economic and racial
inequalities are you looking to change
things that have nothing to do with the
coronavirus and we're not impacted by
that mr. mayor Maria I'm looking to go
at the very things that the coronavirus
crisis has dredged up and we've seen it
all over the country there are vast
healthcare disparities that have come up
that must be addressed for the good of
all of us it's the right thing to do but
also to have a strong healthy society
but Maria what I'm talking about in the
first instance when we talk about just
getting on our feet again I think we all
can count here if we're missing seven
point four billion dollars and now we
heard today there may be additional
state budget cuts looming on top of that
that will hit New York City and the
whole rest of the state we won't be able
to provide the basic services and have
the personnel we need who do that
amazing work you know where we're
talking about the heroes the first
responders the health care workers the
essential workers these are the folks
who need to keep their jobs going
forward if we're going to have a healthy
recovery and if we are guessing billions
and billions of dollars how on earth are
we supposed to do that
Tamara honestly I need an hour with you
there's so many important things to
cover in New York you made a very good
case just there you said that the city
needs to be made whole number one how
are the conversations going with
President Trump or are you going to get
that money and number two mr. mayor
something that you know I've been
railing about about the inmates being
let out now coronavirus is ripping
through our prison systems and now
you're letting inmates out the New York
Post with a headline dozens of New York
City inmates back in jail after
coronavirus relief you're letting them
out there committing crimes and going
right back in even before this between
January and March on the heels of your
bail reform law car thefts up 65 %
robberies up 24% burglaries up 22% we
know you have your hands full mayor what
are you gonna do about it well come to
your question about the president in a
moment mariya real quick
there was a bail reform law passed by
the state of New York not the city the
state of New York there were some things
I thought needed to be better in fact a
lot of us agreed the Governor Cuomo and
I and many others agreed there needed to
be changes and the state legislature did
make important changes a few weeks ago
and I think it's going to help us fight
crime but remember the NYPD has done a
remarkable job crime in New York City
today the last time it was this low was
the 1950s so we've had some challenges
last few months but overall crime
continues to go down in New York City
and YPG's done an amazing job in terms
of the folks who were in our jail system
we let 1,400 out who either had very
low-level offenses or had an immediate
health danger because of the corona
virus they're being monitored when the
jails are able to and the court system
gets back up and running we'll bring
back anyone who needs to be brought back
some have done the wrong thing and
they'll pay the consequences the vast
majority haven't but it was about
protecting lives of Correction officers
and inmates in a humanitarian crisis
President Trump and I have spoken
several times about the stimulus look
I've given President Trump credit when
he's helped in New York City and
sometimes he and his team have done a
great job at that you and I Maria have
talked about Peter Navarro and the
effort to get us supplies and equipment
that's been deeply deeply appreciated I
thank the president for that where I've
been in disagreement with him is he has
still not spoken up for the stimulus to
help cities and states and he needs to
speak up with energy to move the Senate
he understands the economy he
understands New York City if we can't
pay for basic services we won't have a
strong economy we need to hear the
president's voice we're not hearing it
so far mr. mayor I want you to come back
to talk about what New York City and New
York will look like when we get out of
this I want to know what the subways are
gonna look like are they gonna be
different I want to know in terms of
getting back to work will you come back
soon so we can talk about that because
we haven't covered enough mr. mayor it's
great to have you today thank you sir